Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 16th,
2013 and I am recording here on,
um,
it's actually December 17th.
I'm finally back from Europe.
Uh,
I apologize for the podcast
being so late, but, um,
I was in Iceland and when the fuck
am I ever going to be there again.
So I had to do some shit Sunday and then
Monday I was flying all the way back
and uh, I'm actually not that
jet lagged. It worked out nice.
I tried and I tried to, I tried
to stay up on the plane. Oh.
Try to stay awake as long as I could a
for most of the flight because I knew
that I was landing.
MMM.
At 7:00 PM La time,
seven 25 or something.
So I figured if I could just
fucking stay up, you know,
Nia picks me up the airport. I just get
my ass home and then if I fall asleep,
it'll be like nine,
10 o'clock at night and I'm back on
the clock and it worked out good.
I woke up right. But we do
little dude. And I looked at
the clock. Why, why, why, why,
why?
And I wondered what the fuck time it was.
I thought it was like two something
in the morning because my clock,
it fell off the bed day or the digital
one day that I've had since to fucking
seventies there.
And uh,
I thought it said two 30 in
the morning and I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding
me. I thought, I, I thought
I did it right. And uh,
then all of a sudden I'm at six o'clock
and I realized the clock was upside down
and that was five 30.
Is this even remotely exciting?
I don't know if it is or not.
I'm trying to keep my voice down because
the lovely knee is still sleeping
upstairs. Beautiful Angel
that she is. And uh,
I got my dog down Ham psyched
going to go hiking today.
Get back into it.
I swear to God I don't have the
nerve to step on the God damn scale.
All right.
And if I sound like some skinny bitch,
well fuck you.
I'm in this business and I read your
tweets and I see when you see my face,
you start calling me a fat cunt.
All right.
And I gotta tell you it hurts
sometimes, right? No, seriously, no.
I'm saying you gotta be if
you're in this business.
So I think I put on at least 10,
12 pounds.
I started eating like a
fucking Goddamn Roman God
three weeks ago in Italy. And
it never, it never stopped.
I kept thinking to myself like, all
right, when a, when the tour starts,
when the tour starts, I'm going to
be fucking good. And we discipline.
But it just didn't work
out that way. It was, um,
okay.
This past week, I just, uh, I
think I mentioned it last week.
I did a seven country,
seven city run and uh,
what was it? Six cities? London, Dublin,
Helsinki, Copenhagen, also Sweden.
Okay. Six. But I did two nights in
London, so it was seven nights in a row.
MMM.
Basically touring like a band, how
they do it. And I have a whole new,
for anybody that's touring as a band.
And that was hard enough to do
by myself with no equipment.
I don't have to bring anything. I just
fucking show up. Mike and I, Mike Stand,
go up to the microphone.
I love when they want to or you want
to do a sound check? It's like, well,
did it sound okay when you talked to
do it? Well, yeah. Well, there you go.
What am I gonna do? Go up there.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Cunt con con,
you know. So anyways, uh,
I lost another mixer on this fucking trip.
Fool me once.
Shame on you, fool me twice.
Oh, red faces a dumb fuck. Uh,
there's something about these hundred
dollar mixers. Believe it or not,
they don't have any sort of a,
I dunno,
something to prevent the surge.
I don't know what it is
because I had the adapter, um,
or the converter or I should
say convert and all the adapter.
I forget what that fucking guy in
Helsinki dressed me down two years ago on.
It does not a a,
doesn't though.
You are not converting the electricity.
You are adopting it towards your devices.
Yes. Oh, fuck you. Hans.
Um, uh, what's the,
no, it's a good Swedish name.
I don't, our fin finished name.
I have no fucking idea. This podcast
is going to be all over the map.
I Apologize One more time for the,
uh, the sound quality here. Um,
you know my mixes, shit, the bed,
I just discovered that. So, uh,
but the good thing is the
all things comedy networks,
new studios are up and running and um,
hopefully,
uh,
I have a nice surprise guest that
I'm going to try to be interviewing.
He's got a big movie coming out.
Look at me, teasing it, teasing it,
tickling you with it.
Uh,
but I don't want to say that he's going
to be on it because I know he's fucking
busy doing press for it. But, uh, I
ran into him when I was in Dublin,
which was the greatest fucking thing ever.
Him and his friends were fucking hype
in the movie and I was in Dublin and we
just went out and fucking drank and sang
Christmas songs. It was fucking awesome.
Such a great tour. And, uh, yeah,
at the risk of being Corny,
I got to tell you at one point I was
doing the second show in Finland and I had
this feeling when I was on stage that
I was doing exactly what the fuck I'm
supposed to be doing in life.
I can't explain it.
There's something about making people
laugh that far away from where,
uh, where you live and
where you speak a language.
And if you're still connecting that,
that's pretty much about as great an
affirmation that, you know, I'm really,
I'm supposed to be doing it.
This shit is still working this far away.
Um, oh, what a fucking week.
What a week. I got sites,
subs right now I did a show in Dublin,
Ireland and all
the crowds were great,
but I gotta tell you those fucking
people in Ireland as a funniest,
I can't even explain.
Okay.
I sweat it.
Well,
there's something about like when I
go through Great Britain and Ireland,
it's like Scotland and Ireland.
They liked the knuckleheads that I
grew up with and when I go to London,
London is like,
was,
is kind of like all the people that I met
when I went to New York that were from
Boston. So they, they did move
away from where they were from,
but they still brought that thing with
them cause people in London are hilarious.
But I was doing a show Dublin
on Monday night at the,
the, the vicar, a vicar street theater
or something. Just this awesome venue.
By the way, Jim Gaffigan's going to
be there if any UI, Irish console.
Listen to this. You got to go see him.
I was supposed to tweet about that.
I'm going to do that today. I'm hilarious.
Jim Gaffigan's going to be there. Um,
and uh, anyway, so it was,
it was on a Monday night and it's a
really hard night to try and sell tickets
and these people showed up in force
and I can't even tell you how they,
they,
they were fucking hilarious.
Like I was on stage and there was this
thing I was talking about about people
hugging their kids and how
that could put is a good thing.
But if you do it too much it could
potentially make a week or so.
I mentioned it all.
I've been telling this story for like
six to eight months and I've been saying
how that, you know, my
mother wasn't a hug,
hug her and didn't hug us when we were
kids and people just listen and it's just
a small detail that leads to this
other part that I want to talk about.
So I've said that line
uneventfully that's even a
fucking work with, with no,
no issue whatsoever for like six months.
Now I'm in fucking Ireland and I just
throw that line out there like I'm not
even thinking about it and
say, yeah. I said, you know,
my mother didn't hug me when I was a kid
and I'm getting ready to say the next
sentence. And like 15%
of the crowd goes, aw,
I'm not even doing it the way they did.
It just collectively broke my boss.
It was just such the classic fucking,
it was like that Boston Irish thing that
I grew up with distilled to its purest
form with actually real Irish people were,
I,
you'd almost have to be that a
fucking understand what was behind it.
It was like I opened the emotional door,
just a crack in automatically.
It's just,
they just bust your balls about it.
Like, ah, you're fucking, you know what?
Like you think they,
I think we got hugs.
You freckled can't shut the fuck up and
tell the judge I can't even, it just, I,
I've been trying to, I would
try to explain it to Nia.
She laughed, but still, yeah,
you kind of had to be there and
you know,
so I left that when my fucking
trying to get your sympathy,
I'm trying to get to this mess.
Next part.
You assholes and the whole crowd fucking
left. And then like a half hour later,
what I had done when I was over there
was I bought a bunch of DVDs with me. Um,
like just the,
uh,
basically the DVD itself
with this little paper thing.
And I was just handing them out to people
cause I'm trying to get them to show
other people,
you know,
when I'm out there so
I can keep coming back.
Basically trying to get them to
spread the word and my comedy.
And then someone's just like,
well why don't you just put it on Spotify?
You dumb fuck. And I'm like,
yeah cause I'm old. Alright.
I feel like I have to bring the hard copy.
So I tell these assholes
that I'm giving him free DVDs at the
end of the show and I'm halfway through
that Spiel, telling them that they're
getting a free DVD. All right?
And I'm in the middle of it and I hate
this guy in the back of the crowd goes,
Oh fuck off.
I don't even think I even
explained what I was doing.
I don't know if I had gotten to
the part where they were free.
I don't know what the fuck.
Always the fact that I was trying to
once again go to a nice place where, hey,
you know,
I really appreciate you guys coming out.
This really means a lot to me and I want
to keep coming back here cause I think
you've got a great comp country
or whatever it. And I said,
just opening the door that much.
Oh fuck off.
So I finally just looked and I went,
Jesus Christ,
they were already laughed and I was
like, you know what? I played in 20,
almost 22 years as a comedian.
I have played in front of some
miserable motherfuckers but you guys,
and they were already laughing or the
most miserable fucking concert I've ever
been in. And they loved it,
absolutely loved it. And um,
it killed me that I couldn't go out
drinking with the crowd cause they had a
fucking go a head, an early flight of
course, all the way over to Helsinki.
But um,
and it was just kind of those moments
all the way through the tour that were
unreal. Like, uh, in Helsinki, I hope
I'm not boring you guys with this shit,
but I'm in Helsinki.
I did two shows and the first show I
went out and I just like felt like I
couldn't get on a roll for
like a lot of the show.
Like I that get last
and then it would stop.
I would get laughs and then it would
stop. And I was like, and, and,
and it got to the point that there
was one point in the first show that
something I said bombed so hard that
I almost got a little depressed.
And I definitely thought,
because in my head I was
thinking about like, wow,
I think I've reached the limits to where
my act works once I get on the other
side of the Baltic Sea.
And you really feel that when you get
on the other side of the Baltic Sea,
you get that feeling like, you know,
we're, I'm not in Europe anymore.
You're starting to feel like I am
heading towards the Soviet Union. Um,
even though, you know, a good one,
20% of that country is in Europe or
you just get this, I can't explain it.
You're definitely,
you're in eastern Europe.
You starting to get like that Baltic
Slavic fucking vibe and, and um,
I had to use all these tricks that I've
learned as a comedian over the years to
basically stop the, uh, I dunno what the,
the proverbial comedy jet from
going into a spin and you know,
crashing into the ground. I just
committed harder. I started, um,
Improv on f trying to tag
every joke with something new,
something to get me present.
Um, and I was able to,
I still had a good show and everything
and I know they had a good time,
but I was thinking in my head like, man,
this guy wanted me to go to Astonia,
which is basically like a fucking
50 minute boat ride from, uh,
Finland. And I was thinking like,
there's no fucking way I'm going there.
I think I've reached the end.
And then something happened during
the second show or I was talking about
getting a gun and how I liked this one
gun because it was quieter and those
bigger ones at too fucking loud and if
you pull the trigger you're going to
fucking destroy your ears and
they're laughing and shit.
And then as I come to the end of the joke,
you know,
they laughed and then it was kind of quiet
and then some guy in the crowd yelled
out, you know, get a
silencer. And I was like,
well silencers are illegal where I'm
at. I know in Jacksonville, Florida,
their legal,
cause I used them but they're illegal.
Rahmat they basically say that,
you know,
I want to murder somebody and I don't want
anybody to know, um, in the next room.
And then it just dawned
on me and I was like, I,
I,
I just,
I've been in front of really smart crowds
before and they laugh and shut up and
laugh and shut up these fucking
guys that people were so smart.
They were sitting there, they were
trying to solve the problem of the joke.
They're laughing at the joke
while coming up with solutions.
So I finally said to him, I said, listen,
I was like, is this what you guys doing?
All right. I'm like, this isn't a,
this isn't a fucking think tank.
It's just a comedy show.
And then I somehow connected with them
in that moment and then I had him for the
rest of the way and I just
started riffing on that.
Anytime a joke would only do okay.
I would just start riffing on like
the solution to whatever the joke was.
And that got them back in it
and I was able to get on, uh,
get on a roll with them.
And um,
it was just kind of that all
all week dude. And I was,
oh my God, fucking Helsinki.
I watched the sun go down at like three
30 in the afternoon from my hotel.
I think by the time I got there. That's
right. By the time I got to Helsinki,
cause I had to connect
in London at a frau. Um,
which by the way is,
um,
if you ever have to go
to Heathrow airport,
I would suggest doing two hours
of yoga before you get there.
It is a unbelievable
test of your patients,
of your cardio is sanity and it's fucking,
and I, of course, you know me, I failed
miserably. I lose my shit at LAX.
Um, put it this way, if
you, if you can avoid,
if you ever go to Europe,
here's a travel tip for you
and you could avoid connecting.
If you're not going to London,
I would highly, highly recommend
not connecting in London because
it's not like connecting in other,
other,
I've never had to.
You get off,
you got to run through a whole terminal
and then wait for a bus that isn't
coming for seven minutes.
And then by the time the bus
comes to so many fucking people,
or there's already too many people,
you got to wait for the next bus and
another seven minutes you finally get on
that fucking thing.
And it is a shit show.
Um,
oh and by the way,
if anybody lights up a cigarette,
it's going to be too foggy for anything,
the land.
So you're going to be delayed
wherever the hell you're at. A,
I went through that fucking thing
three times. Um, it, it's
still, it's still an a,
it's an incredible airport.
It's stills,
just the sheer size of it you have
to respect. But I have to tell you,
give yourself plenty of time
if you can to connect. Uh,
yeah, it's uh, it's a, it's a fucking
nightmare. Um, I don't know what,
so where the hell did I go from there?
I think I went to Copenhagen after that.
Copenhagen. Yep. I did a show there
that was fucking amazing. And uh,
I got you guys got to forgive me.
All the comedians that I work with,
cause I went night after night
after night after night and uh,
you guys had some pretty crazy names.
Uh, I think this guy's name was,
was a Christian or something like that. I
can't remember. Really, really smart guy.
Really cool guy and gave me
a bunch of tags for jokes.
And they were actually really funny. A
lot of times when somebody does that, uh,
the fucking horrific but up and you got
to sit there smiling like, yeah, you know,
we're going to try that.
His were actually great. Um,
uh, so what else? What
else? What else? Um,
AH, fuck. You know what? I just realized
I left it upstairs when I was in Iceland,
one of the two comedians that opened
up for me, both of them were great.
I couldn't understand what the
fuck they was saying, but uh,
one of them gave me a book. I'm going to
hit pause and I go upstairs and get it.
If you guys like, you know, like
those, you don't like those,
those cartoon strips like the far side,
which just a picture and they
write something funny. All right,
well if you like something absolutely
just completely sick and twisted.
I just sit down and record her.
Hang on. I'm going to look,
I'm going to look it up right now.
I got to find this because
it's fucking hilarious. I mean,
he was killing like all the
comics I was with. We would just,
after we did the show, went to dinner
and we were uh, passing the book around,
laughing our asses off.
Let's see. I hate dolphins.
There it is.
I hate dolphins.
A
book.
Where the fuck is it? Come on man.
It came up. I saw when it came up.
Hold on.
I mean one of his uh, one of
his cartoons, there it is,
one of his cartoons has a stick figure.
It like stick figures,
drawings and he's running is a,
it's a father running after his kids
with this like acoustic guitar over his
head.
Okay.
And screaming. It's your
fault. I'm not a rock star.
And then one of the little kids
running away is going daddy. No,
and it's just
another one is you got two guys are
standing over another stick figure that's
laying on the ground and it looks like
it's just blown his brains out and one of
the stick figures looks at the other end,
goes
something like you want to fuck them.
It's just the darkest,
sickest shit he's got two books is other,
one's called something like
my pussies Hungary. I don't
know what it is. This guy,
I don't know how to say his
fucking name. It's just search.
I hate dolphins and the
comedian's name, it's who, who,
who, who will occur. I don't know.
Hug Liquor Dobson and it's spelled h.
U. G. L. E. I. K. U r.
And his last name is d. A.
G. O. S. S. O. N. M. Man.
This fucking focus. Hilarious. Half the
shit. That's funny. As you look at it,
you laugh and then you hand it to your
friend and he's looking at it and his,
you know,
you read what it says and he got to
kind of look at the picture and put it
together. So watching your
friend taken in the joke is,
is I think it's even more enjoyable.
But um,
he was fucking funny man.
He broke my balls when he brought me up,
like switched into English and uh, I
forget him. What the fuck he was saying.
It was just great. And the guy who
came on before, I was also awesome.
They're just really, really funny
people. Dude, Iceland is insane.
You know,
they have an app over there
that basically when you meet somebody
and you want to start dating them,
you just search it and you
see how you're related.
It'll show how you're related.
I want to say that again.
They have an APP over there.
You meet a woman in a bar or a
woman meets a guy or whatever,
a couple of twinkle toes
meet each other there. Um,
you're fucking,
you're just a,
there's an APP that will say,
not if you're related how you're related
because everybody there is fucking
related. Um, and you know
what's funny there? Absolutely.
The fucking great looking people. So I
think they spread it out far and wide.
Oh they, they actually, the,
the cab drivers over, they
have a joke in Iceland. Uh,
and people in Great Britain and
Ireland aren't going to like this.
They basically sit cause people always
talk about how beautiful the women are.
And they said they,
well basically the vikings,
when they would conquer other people,
they would just take all the good look,
good looking women and they would
take him away with them. Um,
talk about the ultimate defeat. Yeah.
Take my farm land. I don't give a shit.
You take all the beautiful women
for the fuck am I supposed to do?
Just kill me now.
So they're saying that they,
they took them all out of Great Britain,
took him out of England, Scotland,
Wales, and Ireland, and they took him
off to Iceland. And that's why they,
women are so much better looking and
that there's no good looking women.
And the other one, which isn't
true, but of course they say that,
but it's fucking hilarious.
Um,
and also they fucking eat everything
because they live on an island.
So when you go to the menu, um,
they had pigeon on the menu,
but I think that that's
their word for dove. Um,
a buddy of mine, he ordered it. I
had a piece of it tasted all right,
little fucking gay me.
And then they also had whale and I was,
the only thing that I didn't like
about Iceland was there's a number of
restaurants that you went into
when you could actually eat whale,
which to me is like eating an elephant.
You know what I mean?
There's just certain animals.
MMM.
You know,
like look,
if they had like a jackal sandwich or
a fucking hyenas sandwich, you know,
this certain animals where you just like,
you know what, you a cut. All right. Or,
or there's enough of you like, I'll eat
venison. I don't give a fuck. You know,
there's plenty of God damn deer running
around with their disease ticks. Okay.
Fucking up the front ends of a bunch of
cars. I don't give a shit about that,
but whales, I mean, they're
like endangered. Oh, he must
not be in danger because,
or at least Iceland doesn't give a fuck.
I don't really understand how that works,
but um,
did you could actually eat one meal
and I was just like, I, that
that was the only thing that,
that upset me when I was a,
when I was in Iceland.
Iceland is fucking unbelievable.
Uh,
you walk around and I recommend
going in the winter time.
Don't go in the summer when
there's a bunch of people,
Jean shorts walking around. Fuck
that. You go in the summertime
and,
uh,
I got this thing, the blue lagoon spa
there that you go into. It's, it's fun.
I can't even describe it to it.
It's fucking insane.
You're in this fucking giant salt water,
like pool that's heated.
There's steam coming off it.
You're surrounded by snow and
everything just looks blue.
It's like you have on those,
uh, someone was saying, uh,
Mitch Hedberg rest his soul,
those blue tinted sunglasses that he
used to where it's like you're wearing
those fucking things. Um, I don't know.
It was an absolutely amazing,
amazing fucking amazing, uh,
trip. Uh, had a great time
in Sweden. I just don't want
to leave any city out here.
Sweden, I performed in this, this
theater. Uh, it almost looked like a,
you were in like a, uh, a circus
tent, but it was a theater.
Like when you looked out, you felt
like he was standing in the middle,
but it was like, cause it was like
in the round, but not totally.
It was like a semicircle kind of thing.
MMM.
And Oslow also was a place I spent
the least amount of time, but I,
I just had a great time for smoke.
The fucking Cuban cigar.
That's another great thing.
Cubans aren't legal and um,
there are ways to get them back
in the country. Wink, wink. Um,
let's just say that daddy is going to
be fucking drinking a lot of scotch over
the next month. Um, and
it's also a great thing too.
If you get buddies who smokes cigars,
you know, he'd sneak something for them.
Um, or maybe you don't, you
allegedly do it. All right,
this is the Monday morning
podcast. Um, all right,
let's get into the advertising
for this week. All right, the man,
great system, man. Great everybody
this season, think the man great.
What is the man great?
You asked or maybe you didn't,
but you're happy that I just
asked that question for you.
They aren't 100% made in America.
America cast iron grilling grades that
are revolutionizing the way people grill
named one of 2012 best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine.
Man grates are the perfect gift this
holiday season. Click on the Manga.
Click on the man.
Great banner at [inaudible] Dot Com
for their 1999 the holiday special.
Remember each Monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush. Again, that's the man,
great grill enhancement system.
Order today@billbird.com somebody was
bitching about the shipping on these
things. [inaudible] actually not NOI
genial. You know, it's more like 35 bucks.
It's like,
dude,
it's 100% cast iron grilling greats
that's going to make your dad or your
brother,
whoever else is into grilling,
make their stakes tastes
fucking delicious forever. Okay?
You can't kick in an extra 15 bucks to
ship the fucking thing and you get a
grilling brush brush, Jesus
Christ. You know what?
I don't know what it is in the Chinese
new year, but I think that she,
this was the year of the
whiny cunt. Um, all right.
All right. What do we got
here? Dollar Shave Club,
everyone for a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar club.com
delivers amazing quality
razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudging to the
drug store for a pack of blades. Uh,
I always tell you guys,
I always get stuck behind either the
person coming in to dry, you know,
12 cases of beer or I get stuck behind
the old lady and old guy that, you know,
I want to get ice cream and develop
film and all that crap. Right?
And they got 20 registers and
the only one is open, you know,
cause they're trying to exploit new
revenue streams. You know the deal. Um,
you don't have to deal with that because
now with dollar shave club for a couple
of bucks a month,
amazing quality razor blades,
it delivered right to your damn door.
That's right.
No more wasting time and no more
getting hit up for like 20 bucks.
Every time you buy razors,
everybody hears getting their dollar
shave club blades. And you should too.
And here's a genius idea. Try replacing
your old shaving cream with Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter from dollar
shave club.com. Trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Um,
don't waste time at the drug store
behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward slash bar or go to [inaudible]
dot com and click on the dollar shave
club banner.
Uh,
keep your stress level low and your
bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money. Go to dollar shave
club.com. Forward slash. Bar.
Um, what did we guys here? Left?
We got two more left.
All right,
we'll do some more podcasting and
then I'll get back to that. So, um,
is there anything else I
can tell you guys about? Um,
oh, here's one. Here's a good one for
jet lag. I like to, uh, fly at night.
Leave wherever you're going.
Like if you're flying east to west,
if you fly around three,
four in the afternoon,
that's also the sweet spot
at the airport by the way.
Cause then he'd come in around two,
one, two o'clock in the afternoon.
And for the most part, people,
wherever they're staying,
they either want to get the fuck out of
there or they want to try to stretch it
another day. So they, they get, you know,
fly between six in the morning to
10 or they start leaving around,
you know, five or maybe seven cause
they want to skip the rush hour traffic.
So that's a good time to go.
And you're basically,
you're flying in tonight so it's easy
to go to sleep. You can get eight hours.
She definitely gonna be jet lagged when
you get to Europe. But coming back,
um,
when did I leave?
I ain't know it sucked.
The only suck when I was coming
back was I was in Iceland,
so I'm halfway across the Atlantic,
the Atlantic Ocean and,
but it was like a zillion dollars and
way more miles than I had to try to get a
nice business class seat.
MMM.
Straight to La.
So I had to fly back to fucking
eighth row connected any frail.
And um,
I was getting off Icelandic air
and switching to virgin air.
So I checked my bag and I had to fucking
go to baggage claim and had to go
through
customs,
go down and get the fucking bag and
then do the bus thing to this thing,
to that thing. With the fucking bag and
dude, you want to hear about a whiny cunt,
Kirsten up a fucking storm.
And then I ended up having plenty of time.
Yeah,
I had plenty of time and ended up
drinking a couple of scotches there and I
talked to some woman who was from
Poland and I was saying, you know,
I had some people come out to my
shows and Poland in Copenhagen. I,
I'd love to go there. And she's like, well
where do you want to go? And I was like,
Warsaw. And she just shook
her head. She say, Hey, you
know, I go there, it's too uh,
too commercial. And she fucking
broke down all the Poland for me.
So I'm telling you guys, you've
got to do it. You got to do it.
If you've got the time or
whatever, or make time, fuck that.
Even if you've got kids,
fuck it. All right,
fuck getting that second flat screen TV.
Fuck their college education.
It's going to be there.
Okay.
They're not going to get a college
education because you spent fucking seven
days in Europe one fucking time.
One time you spent it there
and you dropped him off with,
with the parents to watch them.
That's great.
They're going to be close to
your grandparents. You know,
your parents would get to spend time
with your kids and you'll get to go over
there, get to see the world
from a different perspective.
You got to fucking do it a
highly recommended and you
can do it on the fucking
sheep.
You really can't just get your fucking
asses over there and have yourself a
sandwich sandwich. All right? Um,
I really hope it's many people's,
you know, fucking gold.
You know what's great,
and I've been reading when I was
in Scotland, something I told you,
somebody gave me this book,
David Lee Ross Book that came out in
the late nineties crazy from the heat.
And I gotta tell you, this is
a fucking killer book, man.
And what I love about it
is he's not dishing a bunch
of dirt about van Halen and
going, Eddie's a content, Michael
Anthony and Alex and all that.
He definitely takes a shot here or there,
but he went through a real painful
fucking thing with the ending of that.
And God knows they trashed him enough.
But a lot of it is he,
he's describing what it's like
to be on the road. And um,
right now he's talking about the extensive
travel that he's done talking about.
He ended a tour in [inaudible]
83 with van Halen and Argentina.
So he's with his security guide,
big Ed.
And not to be confused with Eddie van
Halen. This is a different guy, big Ed.
And he's like, well, you know, we
kind of have to go past the, uh,
the Amazon to get back to a la.
Why don't we go there?
And Big Ed was like, Oh yeah, I've
always wanted to go to Africa.
And David leads just like, all right,
close enough, whatever. So they ain't,
he talks about just like dropping a boat
into the Amazon River and going fucking
down the river, up the river, whatever
he's doing, getting dysentery,
feeling like he's going to die,
having 12 second convulsions. Um,
this is a fucking rock star. Who the
hell does this shit, man, it's really,
really amazing. And I, when I
put down the book this morning,
he was about ready go up.
Uh,
he was in the Himalayas, uh, going through
the valley approaching Mount Everest.
MMM.
He has this great theory of
like, you know, because he's,
he's a nice guy that he's
seen all these great cities.
He always brings his bicycle on. Torney
rides a bike through the city at night.
And he said, you really get to see the
city and feel the spirits of the city.
And I was thinking,
fuck man,
maybe I told you this last week is I kind
of had that moment when I was sitting
there outside the Vatican. You got to
fucking do it. You got to fucking do it.
Okay. And if some shit head
like me who fucking flunked,
didn't flunk everything in
high school, but I swear to
God, I got C's, D's and e's.
They weren't called apps where
I was from a, it was a fucking,
I told you this before,
when I was a freshman in high school,
I was going to go to Notre Dame and
become a lawyer and by the time I was a
sophomore I was like, well maybe I'll get
into roofing. That's how bad I did. Um,
just completely shit the bed,
the bed like fucking fumbled the punt,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
MMM.
Yeah, it was awful. So, uh, so anyways,
that's, that's my travel talk. All right.
That gives all the people who hate sports.
When I talk about a,
when I talk about sports too much on
the podcast, I gave you a break and uh,
I have no fucking idea what is going on
in any sport other than hockey cause I
got the Bruins App on my phone and uh,
I know they had a great west coast trip.
You've got their asses kicked too on my
hand it to him or asses kicked our asses
handed to them or asses kicked to him.
Is that a new one?
I got my ass kicked to me.
It's like they removed your ass and as
you then they walked across the street
and then punted your ass back over to
you because they felt so bad about the
beat death. They go, there's a new
one, um, by the Vancouver Canucks.
So it was funny. They're all
giving me shit on Twitter,
uh, doing that stupid, this,
this, this being the Bruins.
Six to one. Priceless self.
I don't know why you would say
that to me. I'm like, well, uh,
losing the first two games in the finals
and coming back to win five out of the
next six or five. Oh wait, wait a
minute. That doesn't make sense.
Does it for the next five, Jesus Christ
bill, there's my high school math again,
losing the first two and then coming back
to win for the last five in game seven
and you're fucking building.
I think that's a little bit better
to win a Stanley Cup. All right,
so congratulations on your regular
season win and all you cuts out there who
have given me shit because the
patriots lost to the dolphins.
All you fantasy football
playing fucking morons. Okay.
Who actually think that
Brady's lost to step in.
They're so fucking dumb when it comes to
watching sports and analyzing what the
fuck's going on because you get your
nose half an inch away from the paper
looking at numbers.
Uh,
you better wake the fuck up because
there's only like another week I guess of
regular season football.
Tom Brady is in the middle of one of
his greatest seasons he's ever had.
The fact that they have
the record that they do
with,
uh,
the level of injuries and the shift
that as people we lost to free agency.
It's been fucking unreal.
Like somebody brought me on Twitter,
like really hadn't had a fuck do lose
to the dolphins. It's like, well,
first of all, it's easy if you score less
points than they do in second of all,
whenever you play a division rival,
they see it twice a year. Every year.
They know who you are, they know what
the fuck you do. Um, if you're a gambler,
if you ever want to bet on an upset,
I would definitely say bet
that the division rival,
especially if they lost the first time,
is at least going to cover,
if not fucking beat them.
It happens all the time.
I don't know what sport you
fucking watching and, uh,
we have catastrophic fucking injuries
on defense. I'm not making, I might,
I actually, I am making
excuses, but like, um,
what I'm really saying is that if I was
in the states and I was watching the
patriots versus the dolphins, there's no
fucking way that I would just be like,
oh, there's no way we're not going
to win this game. Um, so anyways, uh,
that's all I know about what's
going on in football. Um, I,
I completely missed the
Cleveland browns game,
I guess with the Patriots got all those
new age calls where it doesn't seem like
it's football anymore,
you know what I mean? Um,
so anyways, uh, let's get onto some,
let's get on some,
oh,
and I got a new TV show whenever
I go overseas and I'm jet lagged.
I always put on Netflix and I get into
something else, or I buy a box set,
I got into the killing.
I don't know if anybody's watching that,
but I am three episodes in and I'm
watching every second of the series.
Phenomenal series,
definitely not for the emotionally light.
Uh,
you don't want to deal with something
that's pretty fucking heavy and they do
not pull any punches.
They take you,
they walk you right through it
where you feel like you're living,
living it. It's, it's a amazing
fucking amazing show so far.
Phenomenal, which shot the
acting and all that type of shit.
And I'm looking at him like, fuck,
I'd love to be on a show like this.
So who knows. I'm going to bug
my agent today. Hey, can I, yeah.
Can I play a body or something
on that show? I'd love to
be on it. Um, anyways, um,
I want to thank everybody for joining the
podcast. Tee shirts. Uh, my tee shirt,
uh, slash podcast guy,
Andrew Feminists, uh,
slash standup extraordinary who will also
be at that New Year's eve show at the
Wiltern out here in Los Angeles.
If you want to see the
crew of knuckleheads that
gets fucking hammered every
year out on the golf course, they're
going to the rose bowl. It's Andrew Demo,
Emily's Joe Bart, Nick J, law head,
Jason Lie had in myself and there are
very limited tickets left. So, um,
if you need a few plans fell through,
come on down. We'll make you laugh.
And um, I dunno, I think we're
going to stay, stick around,
do a countdown and all that.
We're going to be boozing it up.
Love to see guys down
there. But um, anyways,
he was mentioning that I
believe the podcast t shirts
are sold out at this point
for the most part, except for
some of the bigger sizes, I think.
MMM.
And if you have any
problem with your order,
the email to check in is a bill burn.
merge@gmaildotcomalllowercasebillburrmergedmdrchatgmail.com.
Uh, we take pride in getting
this stuff out to you.
I think Andrew's done a great
job. Really, really killed it. Uh,
but let us know if you're
having any problems.
MMM.
You know, we are human beings. We do fuck
up, but we don't want to fuck you over.
So let us know if there's a problem as
soon as possible and we'll make it right.
Okay. All right. Here we go onto the
questions and the lettuce this week.
Finland show. Hey Bill, loved to
show in Helsinki. Well thank you. Uh,
I definitely pay to see you again.
I don't know if it was just me.
There were a few moments where I felt
you worried about offending the audience
or something that's extremely hard to do.
Yes.
See would probably there at the first
show. I was feeling you guys out, man.
And I think I also had that long
flight from Dublin where I got,
I got delayed at a fro,
connected in AFL
and I literally landed, went right to
the show. So I might been just a tad off.
He said, that's extremely hard
to do a here's the next time.
Don't worry about any, any of
that. The less you pull punches,
the more you're gonna get out
of the audience and Finland.
Oh, that's awesome man.
Thank you. Thank you for a
reading from your playbook. Why?
I think I figured you guys out.
As I just mentioned the story,
a story on the podcast. Tell
them that, that story anyway,
he goes, PSB, ex girlfriend was
a ginger. She was a real cunt.
MMM.
I didn't even know she was a
ginger until I took her pants off.
Okay.
Ah,
Shit.
I fucking funny.
Um,
yeah, no, you know what it was was
I came out and I, it's just like,
you guys are really fucking like Surrey.
Any comic who's going to
play Finland over there?
There's like mean I can't say this is
just my experience because it was my
fucking jetlag,
my act that I was doing and whatever the
fuck was going on with me chemically.
So I can't say that this is
going to happen, but, uh,
there are fucking great crowd and now
this guy is saying that you can't offend
them. You know what's great when
you go through all of those? Um,
I basically did all of a,
the Nordic countries,
I've told you guys this before,
Scandinavia consists of Norway,
Sweden and Denmark.
And those three countries that
Scandinavia, but within them,
Scandinavia is part of
the Nordic countries.
And that includes all of Scandinavia,
the three, I just, and then Finland,
Iceland, and I think they're
called the federal islands.
That's the only place I didn't go.
The Faroe Islands,
which are like northwest of Scotland.
Um,
but what's great when you go through
all of that is for the most part,
it's predominantly Lutheran,
Lutheran or a Lutheran,
I don't know how to say properly,
but they,
and they basically believe
that when you die, you're dead.
You just go into the
ground and it's just like,
and I say, well, don't you
wonder, like, can you wrap
your head around not existing?
And they're like, yeah, it's
just like before you were born,
you don't remember that same thing.
And
okay.
Because of that, they're
really fucking logical. Um,
if that, it makes sense, if that's
any comedian listened to this,
I would basically describe the,
give it to a college gig.
And you think you're bombing, but
then you realize, oh wait, these,
this is a really smart school.
And they just laugh in a different way.
That's basically what a Helsinki was
like. So, uh, thanks for the heads up.
I did have a great time.
Um,
and I hope those people on the first show
had a good time too. I was, you know,
I don't want to let people down,
you know,
I'll make sure I give him the whole
fucking thing. And I told him,
I made a rule that I wasn't going to
bitch at all on this tour because I knew
what was going to be brutal going from
place to place to place to place everyday.
Fucking waking up,
going to the airport,
landing and then trying to figure out
how fuck making my jokes work. Um,
so because I made the rule
that I wasn't going to bitch,
I only bitch like 30 times
as opposed to like 3000,
although if you counted each
individual bitch going through a frown,
connected any foul, um, that I'd
probably pitch like 700 times.
But I was compartmentalizing.
That's a word to a Heathrow airport.
Um,
for the most part. All right.
Hey, bill, loved from Morocco.
Um, Bill, before I start,
I just want to let you know that my
sister and I attended your show in London
last week. Uh, you did a great job,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Uh,
you had the whole crowd. It's
puppet, blah, blah, blah.
But enough with the ass kicking. Okay.
Here's a little conspiracy theory for you.
At the end of the show, we had a little
argument about your ghosts segment.
Yeah.
I don't believe in ghosts,
which was fucking hilarious to go through
a place that doesn't believe that you
go anywhere when you die.
You know,
when I was going through Scandinavia
in the Nordic countries, because I was,
I'd be like, usually when I say there's
no ghosts, I don't believe in ghosts.
There's someone in the crowd that's like,
oh no, you know, I believe in ghosts.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And they were just sitting there and those
other countries just like, yeah, yeah,
why the fuck would you believe in
ghosts? That's stupid. Is that?
And he goes, he goes, remember when
the your bottle fell off the stool
and the water spilled on stage?
Yeah,
I did this whole segment about
how I don't believe in ghosts.
And I remember when I went to set
down my bottle for some reason,
the cushion on the seat,
it was sort of doing like the leaning
Tower of Pisa thing. So anyways,
I finished the ghost bit,
then I was into some other jokes and
all of a sudden it looks like the bottle
tipped over by itself.
One of those great standup
moments where you can't plan it,
it tipped over itself. And then, uh,
and I didn't realize that
the crowd is reacting and it,
and it was like a full bottle.
So it's just pouring out, um,
got all over the stage and everything.
And then of course I riff that it was
actually a ghost and that is trying to
electrocute me and all that type of shit.
And um, and it worked great. But anyways,
he said, my sister think, thinks
that was part of your act,
the ghost thing. And there was no
way you could be that good at Improv.
I better 50 pounds that it
wasn't planned either way.
It was beautifully done. Do you
mind settling this for us? Yeah, no,
it was not planned. You realize how
cheesy that would be if you plan that.
And also not to kill
the whole improv thing.
It's really not that difficult to come
up with some funny shit when water spills
by itself after you just
did a ghost thing. Um,
it isn't,
you know,
and you don't realize how many times,
I mean,
you fucking Improv,
everybody's improving.
When you walk and you're
having a conversation,
you're totally in the moment
with somebody and you're,
you're without realizing it
because you understand language.
You're listening and
translating and you're also,
which is reminding you some other shit
that you're thinking about that adds to
where the conversation
goes. Um, what it is.
So everybody can do that. It's just
when you get on stage, it's, it's,
you're,
you're going on stage starting your career
and you're dealing with stage fright
and forcing yourself to do this thing
that scares the shit out of you,
which causes you to think, which shuts
down all of your improv abilities.
But over the years,
as you do it,
you get more and more comfortable and
you become as comfortable on stage as you
are offstage.
And then once again,
you tap back into that power of improving
that everyone in the crowd is already
doing. Um, but for, but it's just
not defined as it. So that's,
that's basically what it is. So
no, that was not, that was a,
uh,
that was not planned.
MMM.
Actually had another great one that I
was doing a another great moment I should
say.
It's not like can pat myself on the bed.
I had another great moment of Improv when
I took the Mike's dad and pretended it
was a skinny little bit. Um, and she,
she held eat something for an hour. No.
Um,
I was in Iceland when I walked on stage.
They had a fucking giant Christmas
tree just to the right of the stage.
All lit up looking beautifully.
But I saw,
I went into this stupid thing where I
was acting like it was stealing focus and
I was being a diva and I refuse to tell
any more jokes until somebody's fucking,
what are you Reykjavik sons of bitches
comes up here and takes his God damn tree
down.
And I went on this whole long thing and
it just happened right at the beginning
of the show.
I just saw it and I just,
I dunno,
I just fucking started talking about
it and it killed and they loved it.
And then later on in the act,
I apologize to the tree like it was,
you know,
like I was in some abusive
relationship with it. Like, hey listen,
I'm sorry about what I said
earlier. You're not, you know,
I feel about Jay and blah blah blah, and
just kind of went on this thing. Like,
that's the most fun thing as a comedian
was when you get comfortable enough to
do that shit because I'm not going to
lie to get you get sick of telling you
jokes.
Um,
but anyways, he finishes
off. He says also,
I've been introducing you to my Moroccan
friends over the years and as soon as I
can get 10,000 people like you,
I'll email you so that you, uh,
so you can come visit. Um, thanks and
go fuck yourself. Well, you know what,
send a fucking email to a bill,
burn merchant,
gmail.com and Andrew, we'll
hopefully get back to me. Maybe a,
I could figure out some fucking,
uh, I'll send you some promotional,
a promotional package of some shit.
I'll send some of my,
my ways over there and a young thing
you gotta do is hand them out to your
friends. Okay. That's it. All right. Um,
where the fuck am I? Oh,
there's the ending. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. All right,
you go fuck yourself too. All right.
Underage girl equation. All right, let's
hope this doesn't get creepy again.
A bill, longtime fan listener caught a few
shows. Glad you kicking ass. Thank you.
Ah, here's the important part
is the important part. Yeah.
Fuck my career. Exactly.
A to calculate acceptable age
differences between partners.
Here's my rule of thumb.
All right,
for those of you who are
just new to the podcast,
I haven't listened in the past couple
of weeks because you have a life. Um,
lately,
lately I don't know what's been going
on but people who have been sending me
these fucking emails and uh,
it's somehow it's like, yeah,
you know, 27, my girlfriend's 19,
we've been dating for six years and
uh, it's like, wait a minute, wait,
what the fuck? You know, it gets weird.
So this is what he's referring to.
He goes,
here's the important part to calculate
acceptable age differences between
partners.
Here is my rule of thumb.
Half Your Age plus seven,
that's it works for everyone pretty much.
If you're 22,
half your age is 11 plus
seven equals 18. Uh, dude,
I got to say 22 to 18. That, is that
still a still a huge age difference but,
but it is legal.
It is legal.
I don't know how you don't feel like
fucking Matthew mcconaughey in dazed and
confused with that one too.
Cause you're literally talking like,
you know you got a mustache
by 22. Come on man. She's 18
yeah,
finishing up high school.
Okay.
And you've just wrapped college. That's
a huge age difference. But you know,
26 to 22 is not a big deal.
Yeah.
Um, anyways, but I like, I like what
you're saying. You said 18 is your cutoff.
So yeah, that does make
sense. It is legal. He goes,
if you're a d half your age is 40
plus seven is 47 boom. There it is.
Again, reasonable differences
regardless of age. Yeah.
It depends on who you are and that one,
I think I would rather be the 80 year old.
I feel like I'm stealing money at that
point. But I like, I like what you get,
where you're coming from here. He
goes, I'm not saying there aren't,
there aren't anomalies out
there for every situation,
but for a simple guide to
not being a pervy fuck bag,
stick with the half plus seven rule.
Uh,
been meaning to share
this with you for awhile,
but seeing is every week we seem to have
a new douche bag trying to justify as
perversion. Well, it's time. Yeah.
Thank you. All right, there you go.
People half your age plus seven.
If it doesn't fuck a workout while half
your age plus seven and she's still 18
or older,
right?
Cause if you're 18 half year,
age is nine plus seven is 16.
I mean,
you're in trouble there.
That's statutory rape.
That's still kind of works out good.
I'm 16.
Half my age is a plus seven is 15.
That fucking works.
Okay.
You're 12 half your age is six plus
seven. She's 13. You fucking slaying it.
I love this theory.
I love this fucking theory.
God dammit. That works.
This son of a bitch,
he's like Matt Damon and that fucking,
uh,
where he's got the mop and he's good at
math one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Dazed and confused fucking,
uh, I got to see about a girl.
What the fuck is it called?
Goodwill hunting.
They get go. I shook it loose.
Um, oh, you know what I watched,
I watched a couple of movies. I watched
all Boston guy movies, Mark Walberg.
I watched the one with him and the rock.
I did fall asleep because
I was trying to stay awake.
That has nothing to do with the movie.
I loved any move up fucking
weight lifting. It's got
mark Walberg in it, right?
That takes me back to the 80s when
nobody did squats and everybody just kept
fucking, you know, doing
upper body, upper body.
Um, I got a friend of mine, comedian,
uh, it, Boston, Wayne Brevity's stories.
Talk about that.
How back in the day nobody used to
fucking do squats and then you just put on
your puffy pants.
You see Kava reaches over there to try
to make it look like you had thighs,
video. Um, so anyways,
I watched that one. Uh,
whatever that movie was. I never remember
the names. Then I watched the, uh,
the Matt Damon movie where he's in
the future and they put that thing in,
that bionic shit around them. Fucking
great movie. Just fuck. That's a,
that's a great fucking movie.
I, I stand by both of those.
And also I watched a movie called,
uh,
called drinking buddies that,
um,
Jesus Christ, I never watched a movie. It
was about dating and that type of thing.
I never watched a movie where I felt like,
uh,
I was kind of every guy in the movie,
you know what I mean?
Like the guy sneaking around
fucking around the guy,
the PSAP taking back,
the girl that's fucked around,
the guy wants to commit,
but can't the guy who fucking not
committing the whole God damn thing. Um,
it was a really, I really enjoyed that
movie and it had a, who's had gotten it?
Olivia Wilde, uh, Jake Johnson,
who I fucking worked with on, um,
AH, Jesus Christ new girl. I
swear to God, man, I can't,
I can somebody send me some fish pills,
whatever the fuck he supposed to take.
I can't remember anything. A
really enjoyable movie. Um,
sort of it is my movie plugs for this
week. What else do I got here? Uh,
let's do some advertising
here. Um, Hulu plus everybody.
You probably tried hulu.com with Hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime, anywhere. Dude, I'm telling
you, this right here is the future.
A Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit TV shows and a selection of claimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
streams in HD every time for the
best viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current
TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You can also check out exclusive
content including Hulu originals,
like the awesome starring SNL Seth Meyers,
who by the way as his own talk show coming
out at the beginning of the new year.
Look for that and move boy starring
Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection
of a claim films for only seven 99 a
month. You can stream as many TV shows
and movies as you want, wherever you want.
This really is the future people.
It's just how you're going
to watch TV right now.
You can try Hulu plus
for free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu
plus.com/bill that source,
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill.
Um,
so you get your extended free trial and
that they know that everybody over here
set you.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click
on the Hulu plus banner on the podcast
page at [inaudible] dot com. Um,
that is the future of my friends.
Especially if you travel, I don't know,
you were in college. You don't get,
you're not going to be around
a TV over a friend's house.
She going home for the fucking holidays.
It's just the greatest thing ever. Um,
and last but not least, everybody, uh,
my one is at least we got three
more here. Uh, two more. Sorry.
He voice the holidays are coming.
And as a business owner,
you know what that means?
Crickets face it. Uh,
leading up to the holidays
is the calm before the storm.
Now's the time to do something that will
dramatically help your 2014 he voice.
He voices his simple technology that
helps you make more money with he voices
toll free or local numbers,
call routing tools and a
professional dial by name directory.
Your business will look like a million
bucks and with the voice, if you,
if you can't take a call,
they will transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you.
You'll never get caught off guard again.
Eve voice has been helping companies
save thousands of dollars every month,
making them more efficient
and more productive.
There's no quicker or easier
way to transfer your business
for 2014 and with the
voice you can try it before you buy it.
Jesus Christ.
Can these guys make it any easier? Right
now you can. You can slow it down, Bill.
Right now you can get a
30 day trial to eat voice.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bill burr or go to [inaudible] dot com
and click on the voice banner that's
on the podcast page by the way. Uh,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bill
burr or billboard.com and click on the
voice banner.
Uh,
now's the time to take charge of your
business and prepare for prepare for a
productive 2014 once again,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr
or go to [inaudible] dot com click on
the podcast page and click on the voice
banner for your Free 30 Day trial at
[inaudible] Dot com Jesus
Christ. They got it. All right,
stamps.com everybody the last one here.
Um,
one great resolution you
can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to
do that with stamps.com.
Think about how much time you wasted
going to the post office driving.
They're finding parking stamps.com
is the better way to get postage a,
just use what you already have your
computer and printer to get official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman comes and picks it up.
It doesn't get any more simple than that.
With stamps.com everything you could do
with the post office you can do right
from your desk whenever the hell you want
to do it and at a fraction of the cost
of one of those expensive postage meters.
I've been using stamps.com for months.
Um,
actually no for like a year and a half.
It's about is convening this can as it
can get and I got to tell you with all
this merchandise, you know the
tee shirts and that type of thing,
it would be an absolute nightmare to have
to go to the post office. So anyways,
right now he's my last name
[inaudible] to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait, go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr and then you go,
that is your at Virgin Ms
advertisement for the week.
Your adverts as they say over there
in England. I guess they say that.
MMM.
What are we doing here? Let's go
to the next one. Sparkling water.
The next email here.
A sparkling fucking water
bill pickles. Oh, I get it till
tickles bill a dope deal tickles.
Dill pickles. Bill pickles again. It all
right. There's no one, there is a new one.
My friends,
he said I saw in one of your tweets
that you were upset about accidentally
ordering sparkling water.
Yeah, that happened to me when
I was in, I was in London,
uh,
going to eight round connected any from
okay.
You know, they, they put it in the
clear bottle. It looks just like water.
And you know when you're in a different
country like shit gets hard shit.
You just take for fucking grant like that.
I never accidentally, I very rarely do.
I accidentally grabbed sparkling
water when I'm uh, in the states here.
Cause I know Poland Spring, I know,
I know what the fuck bottled water,
there's still shit looks like. But, uh,
that is the most amazing thing. When you,
when you travel abroad, is this part
of your brain you have to use that you,
you'd never use?
Like I never realized how much
shit I recognized just out a color.
MMM.
And then all of a sudden you go
overseas and he just like, all right,
is that a taxi or a police
car? You know, this,
is that a pharmacy or
are they selling clothes?
And I'm not even joking because the way
that some of the stores look over, over,
over, uh, overseas, they, they,
this style that they'll do the store in,
that's their style for a fucking pharmacy.
All the pharmacies are pretty
easy over there cause they have a,
they have a neon green like cross.
It's really easy to find.
So that's probably a bad one. But
anyways, yeah. So anyways, he goes,
I hope you come around on this score.
It's never too late to change.
MMM.
Oh, I think this guy's just telling me
that he likes sparkling water. Well,
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
why don't you just read the fucking
thing so we can all find out? All right.
He said, you know, men have great
character and sophistication,
have long been enjoying sparkling
water. Oh Jesus Christ. Well,
let me go dress up for this fucking email.
This guy sitting there with
his legs crossed where and
it was an ascot does that
and he said,
he says it's a satisfying bevy that you
can drink endless quantities and endless
quantities of why you battle the
temptations of various other addictions.
Like when you're off the bottle,
I highly recommend reaching for a bottle
of San Pellegrino and as a punch that
plain water or fruit
juice just can't give you,
it's like hard alcohol in the
sense that it's an acquired taste,
uh, on top of the hard
alcohol. A Nice, I can't,
I don't know how to is Cheryl Steiner
mixes wonderfully with alcohol's of all
kinds.
My preference being vodka and Whiskey,
it's a much better mix than fruity
juices and sodas and all that other,
uh,
pussy shit
just cuts a bit. It's like water.
Water is bad ass big brother.
I remember you saying that
you don't drink coffee.
He was saying you've missed out
on all that coffee house posts.
He over the years. So this is one
pairing that I probably can sell you on.
Um,
what, so this is one pairing that
I probably can't sell you on,
but an espresso drink, no sugar
with a Perrier air to hydrate you.
Fucking delightful.
Or I know you've been to Italy and
antipasto plate with a glass of wine and a
glass of sparkling water. Uh, Bueno.
I hope I said that right. I don't
have one off. B u. O n o uh,
love the stand up.
Love the podcast as a working poor type
nine to five or the podcast makes Monday
almost bearable. Look at you
getting all fucking, he goes,
wait for the Canadians hockey cities dates
here in Montreal. Not a habs fan. Uh,
senators fan. All right.
Um, yeah, I do it.
I don't like drinking carbonated shit.
I think it makes you bloated and
makes you fat for no fucking reason.
And you should be drinking water.
Uh,
I'm not into the shit and when I'm off
the bottle I just get off the bottle
totally.
And I drink water.
And then I looked down and my stomach
getting flatter every day and I fucking
enjoy it. But uh, yeah, I'm just not a a,
I'm not a sparkling water guy and I'm
just not, I don't like the shit. Uh,
if I'm going to drink
something carbonated,
I'll have a soda or pop or a pap is they
see in the Midwest and what do I like?
I like the Mexican cocacola that
has the real sugar and I like 'em.
I like Orange Soda, but only if
that has the good sugar too. Um,
all right, dude, the
jet lights hit me here.
I'm just fucking talking about what kinds
of soda I fucking like. Uh, all right.
Opposite of Anorexia.
Yeah. Speaking of which,
I mentioned earlier that I gained some
weight here. Opposite of Anorexia. Hey,
they've built,
I think I might have the
opposite of Anorexia because
when I look in the mirror,
I see a skinny guy.
While I've trained with
pushups and weights and gain
like 10 pounds right now I
am 18 years old, six two and 187
pounds, which should be normal.
Also, when I look at my
classmates, classmates,
I seem bigger and more muscular.
But when I'm home and stare in the
mirror, I just seem skinny. Anyways.
Love your podcasts. Greetings
from Holland. Yeah, Dude. Um,
opposite of Anorexia. I don't
know what that means. Yeah,
but you got some sort of body issue, dude.
If he's six, two, one 87, yeah, you look,
you look fine and you're also 18 years
old, you're going to fill out. Um,
my suggestion is to look into the mirror
and override those negative thoughts
and think something positive. And I got
to tell you, dude, when you get older,
okay,
and you've got to go to the gym for two
fucking weeks to get yourself looking
halfway decent.
And then you have one French and it
negates all two weeks that you did.
You're going to fucking look back and go,
God,
remember when I was six to when I
was 187 pounds for the love of God.
Enjoy this period of your life as much
as you can because there's no way to
enjoy it fully the way some
old bastard like me could. Um,
because I know what it's like now to
fucking do all the work I did and then go
away for a couple of fucking weeks and
come back and look like, oh my God, dude,
I fucking pat on a pullover
sweater the last fucking night.
And I took a picture with somebody and
I was sucking in my gut and I still look
like a fucking, ah, I knew it.
Somebody took a picture of me when I
was at Iceland and I saw, I'm getting,
I'm getting my fat head back
again. It killed me. So Dude,
you're killing it. You're six to,
yeah, 187 pounds. You're 18 years old.
He got your whole life ahead of you.
You should just be focusing on
finding fucking places to go.
Have a good time. All right, go up,
go chat up the most beautiful
women you can find it.
Just have a great fucking time. All
right, put looking in the mirror.
Think and you're some fucking
skinny loser. You're not all right.
You're a God damn fucking rocks.
You're the rock star a year of
your life right now. All right.
And then don't use this as some negative
of goods. Little Down Hill from here.
Stop being a fucking pussy. Go out and
enjoy your goddamn like you look great.
You son of a bitch. Go Fuck Yourself.
All right. Accidentally racist.
Hey Bill, I was waiting in line, uh,
for the Water Fountain at my gym with a
buddy and this African American guy was
taking forever to fill up
his gallon size water bottle.
Don't you fucking hate people
to do that at the gym? Cheap,
cheap fuckers. I get that.
You're doing it. I get it.
But if you see somebody behind you,
you got to gallon water ball.
Maybe it was just the bigger one.
You know what? You'd be a good shit.
Turn around and be like, can you just
getting a drink? Yeah, let me step aside,
you know, be a fucking asshole.
You know what that's like?
That's like people who stand in the middle
of sidewalks with four other friends
and have conversations and the whole world
has to walk around them or they do it
in the airport. If you're
stopping and you, you're,
you're going to make your flight.
Are you trying to figure out
where the fuck you supposed to be?
We'll go grab the wall, get over to
the fucking wall. Let people, you know,
if your car fucking breaks down,
if it's safe to do it,
fucking push it to the side of the
road. You dumb cunt. All right. Sorry.
Anyways, he goes, I was getting
impatient as you should have. He goes,
I remembered that the
gym recently got rid of,
of a separate fountain with a big nozzle
so you could fill up a water bottle
quicker.
So I remarked to my buddy,
didn't they used to have separate
fountains for these people? Oh Shit.
Oh No.
He goes before my buddy can respond.
The African American guy turns
around and says, excuse me,
Q foot and mouth.
Okay,
so the best accidentally
racist story you've got.
Uh, wait a minute, dude. Yeah. I hope you
explain that to them. Uh, you know what?
I have to think accidentally,
right? I know I've done that.
I know I've done that way.
I, what did I do that,
oh, I remember when I was in DC,
I just made a joke in the guy,
didn't find it funny and then
I felt like a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
Um,
it was right after Obama got elected,
I was in DC and I was fucking hammered
and I was coming back to this hotel with
Joe to Rosa. And, uh,
the security guy who was black,
African American said something to me.
And as a joke, I go, oh,
what the president is black
now civil. And I'm hammered.
And I thought he was going to laugh.
And he stared at me like all my,
like this is a white person who actually
thinks this shit. And I was like,
I was just fucking around Joe's
like dragging me away. Like I went,
like it was a joke that would've worked
if I was sober and I was in a comedy
club and I'd set it up right.
But I didn't, oh. And I kind
of fucking knew the guy,
but I didn't know the guy. It was three
in the morning. I was drunk and it like,
dude, it was fucking horrific. And I,
and it kills me that I wasn't able to
explain myself cause I guarantee that that
guy's still fucking at least told
that story for two weeks. So, um,
I dunno, that's actually a good top.
If anybody else has accidentally racist
shit. Oh my God. That's too,
that's like I would submit
that to fucking Larry David.
It doesn't that seem like an
episode of his Shell. You know,
that had happened in the beginning.
Like you don't just whining that he
has to go to the gym and all that Shit.
Bitch moaning and complaining.
He sees the guy with the water
bottle and then the misdirection is,
he talks about how cheap these people
are and he actually defends the gym for
all the water that they're using. Um,
and then when he shows up, it's gone.
And then he stands behind. I mean the
whole fucking thing is right there. Hey,
put that music underneath it. He
got yourself an episode. All right.
Ski Lodges a there. Billy Bunny
Hill. Uh, what's, should take,
what's your take a good weekend.
Come on people, you know,
I can't read out loud.
Can you,
can you at least help me by at least
trying to put all the words from the
sentence in the fucking email?
What's your take?
I'm going to guess on a good weekend of
bagging snow bunnies and drinking hot
chocolate. What's my take on
it? What that sounds like.
One of those fucking titty
movies I watched when I
first got cable. What, what?
Okay.
What? Take what I have on our other
than that's fucking awesome. He goes,
the occasional outdoor hot tub
seen wood fires and turtlenecks,
some marijuana and monopoly
washed down with the dark red.
I don't even ski,
but if I ever start,
it's to be able to live in that dumb and
dumber aspen type scene. Oh, absolutely.
Somebody asked me recently,
asked me if I skied and I said,
I told them that story.
How I,
when I was in that was in Utah with Jay
lie ahead and we stayed an extra day and
went skiing up in, uh, what did they do?
That film festival Sundance.
We were up around there.
We went skiing up there and it was
great. But I, I don't like skiing.
I love the workout and I love all
that aspect that you're talking about.
Like a calming down and they got the
fire going and you drink beers. Dude,
it's fucking awesome.
But I have just never participated
in a more blow your knee out.
Fucking sport did skiing,
but uh,
just your description there like that
right there is why I want to go. Um,
okay
as fuck. And it's just, that's the
shit. Who's that guy? That guy there.
The guy in Holland. There you are the
six foot two one eight s on an 87 pounds.
There you go. Go skiing, go scale.
This is what you should be doing instead
of fucking staring at yourself in the
mirror going, oh, I'm ugly, I'm too
skinny. Fuck that. Do this shit.
Yeah.
You know what?
I want to buy all the skiing shit in and
not go skiing and then just go on the
treadmill and get all sweaty and then
put the ski and Shit on and just act like
I fucking came off the mountain.
Wash it down with a dark red.
How good does that sound? It's
7:34 AM the me. All right.
That's the podcast. A what
is my take on that? Like I,
I think that this is what I would do.
Take skiing lessons.
Something I never did. I
was like, whatever. I play
hockey dude, I fucking skate.
Just shame shit. Nobody's
trying to hit you, right?
You don't realize that there's trees.
You forget that, which is like the, uh,
I can't even, it's like a fucking
defenseman times like 9 million.
You never went in that contact.
You never knocked the fucking tree over.
You basically die like
Sonny Bono or some shit. Um,
I just hate when you fall and like one
are you skis is going one way and the
other's going the other way and
it's never a convenient fucking way.
You always feel like you got
to fucking blow out an ACL.
But if you survive and you get
down that hill a couple of times,
you know what's funny about skiing?
I always love when you get to that point
where you know you're exhausted and you
try to do one more fucking run and you
get up there and you're so tired by you
get halfway down, you just fall down.
Every third time he tried to make a turn,
like whatever that fucking acid is that
builds up and your muscles in your legs.
It just,
you're just completely gassed and you're
laughing and you're friends laughing at
you and you just get down
to the fucking mountain.
You get to the ski lodge.
Hopefully there's not a bunch of
cons taken up the whole thing. Um,
you know that rich family that has five
kids in a can afford to buy them all ski
stuff despite the fact that they're all
growing and shit. Um, you resent them.
They looked like the Kennedy's like,
okay, that was fucking blue blooded cons.
But if you can somehow get yourself a
seat, ah fuck, I want to go. I'm going,
I'm, I'm calling up law ahead. I'm going
to go skiing over the Christmas break.
Fuck this. I'm going, Jesus Christ.
Because they did that person.
Paint a picture of what? I'm
fucking guard. All right,
here's the wrap up everybody. Um,
now that the show's over, once again,
do not forget to sign up for the future
of watching TV, your free trial of Hulu.
Plus once again, Hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV, PC,
smartphone or tablet.
Support this podcast and support your
quality of life as far as viewing.
Get an extended free trial of Hulu
plus when you go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com and click on the
Hulu plus banner or go to Hulu plus
doc.com/bill that's Hulu plus.com/built
and that is the end of the podcast.
And um,
I got it.
I got to thank everybody who
came out to my shows in Europe.
I have to thank all the promoters
who got me out there. Uh,
I got to thank everybody who took
me out, you know, to the bars,
to that premier league
game. Tuh, Tuh, Tuh,
all these sites, all the to the lagoon,
all this stuff. I, I can't even like,
it was absolutely, I'll
never forget that tour. Um,
and I'm just going to
keep going over there.
It was just an unbelievable experience
to end an unbelievable year where I had
some of the biggest shows in my career.
I did the most shows,
the most cities I've ever done.
I did the red state tour,
I did that bus tour through the south
with all my buddies and I'm Jason La,
hadn't his legendary Father Jim lie.
Lochhead um,
just all the people I got to meet,
man.
It was just the exact reason why I got
in this business was to have fun and to
travel and make people laugh. And
I really, I did that this year.
Like, I dunno, it just went to a
whole other level. I don't know.
I can top it next year. I'm
fucking exhausted, but I'm
tired and a great way. So,
uh, thank you to everybody
and uh, that sit man,
I hope you guys enjoy your a merry
Christmas. Happy Kwanzaa, happy Hanukkah.
Happy New Year.
Hope you guys have a nice Christmas break.
And I'm like, I said, man, fucking,
if you can scrape together some quarters,
I get your ass on a plane and go travel.
I wish I did it when I was younger and,
uh, I'm an old fuck man. 45. He never
to never too old to do it. So, uh,
I want that for all of you guys,
man.
I hope you guys have a great
successful 2014. That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves. And, uh,
I'll talk to you next week.